Electrophilic aromatic substitution can be
used to introduce a nitro group onto an aromatic
ring.
The nitro group is an interesting functional
group because no matter how we draw the Lewis
structure, we cannot avoid having formal charges
on it.
Now if we just focus on the extra electron
pair that's making the formal negative charge
on this single bonded oxygen—we can actually
represent this as the negative charge—and
then see how the movement of this electron
pair to make a new double bond here can push
electrons onto the other oxygen, giving it
the formal negative charge.
We can show our delocalization a bit better
by showing this representation; however, this
is not convenient for showing arrow pushing.
In the nitration reaction, benzene can be
reacted with a mixture of sulfuric and nitric
acid to form nitrobenzene.
The mechanism begins with nitric and sulfuric
acid reacting to form the nitronium ion.
In the first step, the stronger acid protonates
the weaker acid.
But, wait a second...
nitric and sulfuric acid are both strong acids.
So how can we tell which is stronger?
Well, we can look at a pKa table and see that
nitric acid has a pKa of -1.3 and sulfuric
acid has a pKa of -3.0.
But we can also look at stabilizing effects
in the conjugate bases.
Remember, when the conjugate base of any acid
is more stabilized, the compound is more likely
to give up a proton because it has stabilization
when that proton is gone.
Let's take a moment to look at the resonance
forms of nitric and sulfuric acid, and see
if we can rationalize sulfuric acid being
the stronger acid.
We can show delocalization in the conjugate
base of nitric acid by pushing electrons from
the oxygen anion through the double bonded
oxygen.
This gives us a total of three resonance forms
for the conjugate base of nitric acid.
Now, let's look at the conjugate base of sulfuric
acid.
Here, we're just showing the first proton
coming off, because that is the one that ionizes
completely.
The second one does not.
In each of these forms, we're going to maintain
six bonds to sulfur, but we're going to push
electrons so that we have our oxyanions forming
sulfur–oxygen double bonds.
We can see for the conjugate base of sulfuric
acid, we also have three resonance forms.
So, what's the difference?
Why is sulfuric acid a stronger acid?
In the conjugate base of sulfuric acid, we
actually have another effect going on.
This inductive electron withdrawing effect
further stabilizes the negative charge in
the conjugate base of sulfuric acid, making
this more stabilized and thus a stronger acid.
Returning to our mechanism, we can now show
nitric acid getting protonated by sulfuric
acid.
If we protonate the oxygen containing the
hydrogen atom, this will make water, which
is a good leaving group.
So, the product of this reaction is a protonated
form of nitric acid and the conjugate base
of sulfuric acid, which we looked at in detail
below.
Now, we have two formal positive charges next
to each other in this molecule.
So, we want to relieve this repulsive force,
and break off water.
However, if we just made water leave, we would
end up with a 2+ charge on nitrogen, which
isn't very favorable at all.
Fortunately, we have that oxyanion right next
door that can push down its electrons assisting
in the departure of the leaving group and
leaving nitrogen with just a +1 charge.
Elimination of the leaving group gives the
nitronium ion, and a molecule of water.
Now, the nitronium ion is a powerful electrophile,
and so benzene will open up its double bond
and attack it.
Now we have a carbocation on benzene that
needs to be neutralized.
It can be neutralized by the deprotonation
of this hydrogen atom.
Now, in this mechanism, it might be tempting
to take the conjugate base of sulfuric acid
to do this deprotonation; however, remember
how resonance stabilized that was from above?
It's not going to be a very good nucleophile
because its electrons are all tied up in that
resonance and that inductive effect.
So, there's a better nucleophile—a better
base—in this solution that we can use for
the deprotonation.
Notice, we made a molecule of water above.
Also, even the most concentrated acids have
a significant amount of water in them.
So water is a much better base to use in this
deprotonation, and gives us nitrobenzene plus
a molecule of hydronium ion.